WILL RESPOND AND TO STAFF UP TO
MEET CUSTOMER NEEDS.
BRET.
>> Bret: MOLLY LINE IN
PENNSYLVANIA.
MOLLY, THANK YOU, FAIR AND
BALANCED.
SITUATION MUCH DIFFERENT ON THE
WEST COAST.
MANY THEIR FEAR IS TARIFFS COULD
CAUSE JOBS WITH PRICES ON
THE RISE.
NATIONAL CORRESPONDENT WILLIAM
LA JEUNESSE IS IN CALIFORNIA
TONIGHT.
>> THE COST IS THE BIGGEST
THING, AND THAT IS WHAT IS GOING
TO HURT US AS A COMPANY, IF THIS
GOES THROUGH.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP HOPES TO
PUNISH CHINA AND SOME OTHERS FOR
DUMPING ALUMINUM AND STEEL, BUT
SOME U.S. STEEL PRODUCERS SAY
THE 25% TARIFF WILL HURT THEM,
AS WELL.
>> IF THEY IMPOSE TARIFFS, YOU
HARM OUR BUSINESS VERY BAD.
>> CALIFORNIA STEEL IS THE
LARGEST PRODUCER WEST OF THE
ROCKIES.
UNLIKE MILLS IN THE MIDWEST,
THAT MAKE STEEL FROM IRON ORE,
CALIFORNIA STEEL IMPORTS ITS RAW
MATERIAL AND SLABS.
THESE 25 TONS LABS ARE HEATED AT
2500 DEGREES.
THEN IT IS ALMOST LIQUEFIED,
PRESSED BY ROLLERS INTO SHEETS
OF STEEL.
>> THOSE ARE FABRICATED INTO
COILS AND PIPES AND SOLD TO
COMPANIES THAT TURN FINISHED
STEEL INTO FRAMING, SOLAR
PANELS, AND MORE.
>> TALKING ABOUT SAVING AMERICAN
JOBS, RIGHT?
WE ARE AMERICAN JOBS.
>> MARCELLA RODRIGUEZ SAYS ONE
PROBLEM IS TRANSPORTATION.
IMPORTING SLABS FOR MEXICO AND
BRAZIL BY SHIP COSTS ABOUT $20 A
TON.
MOVING IT BY RAIL FROM THE
MIDWEST, MORE THAN $100.
>> THE TRADE COSTS TO BRING FOR
MOST COUNTRIES TO CALIFORNIA
COSTS ONE FOURTH OR ONE FIFTH OF
THE FREIGHT COST FROM THE
EAST COAST TO THE WEST COAST.
>> BUT THE REAL PROBLEMS WITH
THE AMERICAN STEEL INDUSTRY,
RODRIGUEZ SAYS, AS CHINA,
DUMPING COILS WITH FINISHED
STEEL LIKE THIS FOR $200 A TON,
WHEN THE U.S. MARKET PRICE IS
400.
>> WE JUST WANT FAIRNESS,
BECAUSE WE HAVE NOT BEEN TREATED
FAIRLY BY OTHER COUNTRIES.
>> RODRIGUEZ WANTS THE PRESIDENT
TO EXCLUDE SLABS FROM THE
TARIFF, OTHERWISE HE SAYS COSTS
WILL RISE, CLIENTS BUY LESS,
FORCING LAYOFFS, KILLING JOBS,
NOT CREATING THEM.
>> A LOT OF US ARE LOOKING TO
RETIRE FROM A COMPANY AND RIGHT
NOW, IT'S A BIG CONCERN THAT WE
DON'T KNOW WHAT IS GOING TO
HAPPEN.
>> THIS WAS KAISER STEEL, A HUGE
INTEGRATED PLANTS LIKE THOSE IN
PENNSYLVANIA THAT MIND OR DOWN
THE STREET BUT IT WENT
BANKRUPT, REPLACED BY THIS MODEL
USING IMPORTED SLABS BECAUSE THE
OWNERS SAY THE MIDWEST COULD NOT
OR WOULD NOT SUPPLY COMPETITOR.
THE OWNER SAY THEY HAVE THE